now the National Grid's forecast
suggests that Supply could be a real
issue this week with this cold snap
across the country what would labor do
to secure the country's energy Supply
or we think this needs a proper overhaul
we should be developing Britain's green
energy resources our wind power our
tidal power this is part of tackling
climate change but it's also about
getting us proper energy Security in
this country and having proper long-term
plans so kirst armor set out a green
Prosperity plan that would be about
investing in that renewable energy of
the future that would cut our energy
bills and also give us that security and
mean we're doing our bit for zero carbon
yeah so that's a long-term plan what
would you do about the real short-term
urgent issues facing people who are now
living in freezing conditions in parts
of the country and you just can't afford
to heat their homes and this would you
what would labor do and that's why we
called for the energy price freeze and
also a proper windfall tax on the oil
and gas company's excess profits because
as a result of the uh
those are those things yeah and they've
still got some loopholes though in the
windfall what difference does that mean
to someone who doesn't have money in the
bank to pay their energy bills so I
think you've got to have the support
we've also called for stronger action on
particularly those who have the
prepayment meters because those are the
often people who've got the real biggest
pressure of all and also you're seeing
people being forced onto prepayment
meters at the moment as well so more and
more people in that situation that is
causing huge hardship for people and
look we shouldn't have been in this
situation because you've seen this
situation coming for a long time the
building up of the conservatives
economic mismanagement we've had 12
years building up to this cost of living
crisis the disastrous many budget that
we had in in the Autumn and now people
being asked to pay the price of that
which is just deeply unfair a really
tough time for people okay onto strikes
now Royal Mail workers striking uh today
this government thinks is economic
impossible to give a pay rise to public
sector workers in line with inflation
would you be able to find the money to
do that well nobody wants to see the
disruptive strikes I think in that
includes also a lot of the workers who
are involved but again people are facing
a real cost of living crisis and that's
why you have to have the plan to deal
with the cost of living crisis and what
we also want to see is government
ministers getting around the table to
actually negotiate some deals to prevent
the the kind of disruption that people
are worried about by getting around the
table and doing deals there's some
really worrying reports that the
ministers had actually stepped in to
prevent the rail strikes being resolved
and to prevent offers being put that
might have resolved the rail strikes
well you know what what are they up to
it looks like they're just addicted to
chaos and trying to make conflicts worse
rather than trying to get around the
table and sort things out so if you were
in power and you were had a spot at
those negotiating tables right now what
would you be offering terms of pay rise
to public sector workers so that's a
matter for those negotiations I think
Rachel Reeves has said should they get
she's not going to pick figures out of
thin air and the negotiations have to
look at some of the the working
condition issues as well because Give an
example for nursing and for the NHS
part of the challenge that people are
facing is having come through the covert
crisis they're understaffed there's huge
numbers of vacancies they're really
stretched and one of the things Labor's
announced is we would have we would
double the number of medical training
places District nurses a huge increase
in the number of trained people as West
streetings said it's like the cavalry's
coming with labor that is what we would
do to to get those extra staff in place
to ease the pressures that people are
facing yeah I'm glad you brought up NHS
workers because you know I've spoken to
a number of nurses morale is at rock it
really is and as you say they're
essential workers there's a huge
shortage of them right now so would you
give them the 19 pay rise that they're
asking for well paying needs to be part
of the negotiations that has to be a
negotiation and as Rachel said it's got
to be the negotiations that resolve that
we do think that people should be paid
fairly and that means that's also why
we've got a plan to grow the economy
because we want people to have better
pay not just in the public sector in the
private Etc as well you've got to have
that plan the reason we're in this
situation is we've had 12 years of low
growth that's why we've then got 12
years of being the Public Services being
run down by the conservatives and
they're making public sector workers pay
the price that is not fair people should
be paid fairly for the jobs that they're
doing absolutely
um but for NHS staff listening you're
not guaranteeing that they would get any
more money under a labor government than
they're currently being offered well the
thing that we're guaranteeing is that
the late ministers will be getting
around the table and would be talking to
them would be working with them and
we'll be trying to get a deal an
agreement in place because we recognize
really the huge pressure that that
nurses and NHS staff have been placed
under the key workers who got us through
this crisis and we would be recognizing
that and recognizing that people do need
to be fairly rewarded but we've got to
have those negotiations in place but
you've also got to have a proper
long-term plan to get the nursing staff
in place and we would abolish the
non-dom status the tax break for some of
the richest people in the country in
order to pay for that that is a fair
choice that labor would make that the
conservatives are currently refusing to
make Rishi sunak is refusing to do that
okay let's move on to migration if I may
the Archbishop of Canterbury is leading
a debate on UK Asylum policy today now
labor says it has an immediate it hasn't
a plan to immediately introduce Fast
Track processing for Albania and other
safe countries an immediate plan what is
that
so at the moment the system is in chaos
decision making in the home office has
collapsed and only around two percent of
people who've arrived in the small boats
over the last 12 months have had their
cases decided for Albania it's actually
less than one percent that's why you've
then got this huge backlog that's grown
up because the home office isn't doing
its job and so what we would do is Fast
Track cases from designated safe
countries that includes Albania so those
cases can be swiftly decided and
returned that's what if sorry if okay
where cases are unfounded then they
would need to be returned that means
your urine then can have a system where
the for refugees there is proper support
for those who fled persecution and
Conflict for those who are not refugees
then the system moves much more quickly
and we do that alongside targeting the
criminal gangs where again the
conservatives have completely failed to
do that but do you accept that it's
complicated some of these people who
come here from Albania are escaping
human trafficking and and other abuses
and indeed the Albanian ambassador to
the UK has said that you know Albanian
school children are being bullied here
in the UK because of this Focus so do
you think that this this rhetoric now
from labor focusing on Albanian migrants
is isn't it damaging so we've already
said this should be about designated
safe countries so that would include
Brazil it would include Moldova it would
include lots of different countries the
reason that obviously there has been the
discussion about Albania is that there's
been a big increase in recent months of
people arriving from Albania but you're
right that the system has to be fair and
there have been cases particularly women
Albanian women being trafficked into
sexual exploitation and abuse and also
Albanian children being trafficked as
well so the system has to make sure that
it looks at the individual cases but you
can still do that and fast track it this
is what other countries do so germ and
Sweden Switzerland it's also what the
United Nations Refugee agency
recommended was a tracking system so
that you can speed cases up they
recommended that to the British
government two years ago the
conservatives have refused to do it so I
think this is a common sense approach
you're right that we've got to be really
sensible about this we can't have the
kind of ramping up the rhetoric that we
have heard from conservative ministers
just common sense instead and just one
quick question on the unite Union if I
may um Sky News broke uh that story
yesterday of allegations of corruption
at unite union now being investigated by
the police if indeed criminality does
emerge will labor hand back the 750 000
pounds in donations that they've been
given by unite there's got to be a
proper investigation you've obviously
raised serious allegations there has to
be a proper investigation and obviously
as Shadow Home Secretary you wouldn't
expect me to comment but if criminals
aware that there is a but if criminality
doesn't emerge I think there was a
criminal investigation underway you
wouldn't expect me as Shadow Home
Secretary to comment on a police
investigation I think that wouldn't be
appropriate they need to be able to do
their job and investigate allegations
and if they find crime has been
committed we give the money back again I
think they've got to be able to do their
job and investigate the allegations it
just wouldn't be appropriate and the
shadow Home Secretary I can't comment on
ongoing investigations so no
confirmation either that you give money
back okay Yvette Cooper thank you very
much for speaking to us thank you